there's always room for dessert here's a
sweet idea just for you
hey hey drew it's marlon shotland with
urban bliss life and today i'm going to
show you how to make these easy and oh
so adorable mini pecan pies
first spray a mini muffin pan with
non-stick cooking spray or grease each
of the cup openings with butter set the
pan aside and start on the crust
these mini pecan pies start with either
store-bought refrigerated pie crust or
your favorite homemade pie crust recipe
roll out the pie crust and use a round
cookie cutter to cut out circles you
should end up with anywhere from 15 to
18 circles
gently push each pie dough circle into a
mini muffin cup pressing the dough along
the sides as well
if you accidentally create a hole in the
crust while doing this simply push the
dough together until there are no holes
next sprinkle the choc pecans into each
cup just enough until the pecans almost
reach the top of each opening this will
be about one tablespoon full
in a large bowl whisk together the brown
sugar corn syrup vanilla egg egg white
and salt
spoon about 2 teaspoons of this filling
over the pecans in each muffin cup
bake the mini pecan pies at 350 degrees
fahrenheit for 18 to 20 minutes just
until the tops are slightly puffed up
and the tops and sides of the crust are
golden brown remove from the oven and
allow the mini pies to cool in the pan
for about five minutes before carefully
lifting each mini pie out of the pan
these mini pecan pies are a great
make-ahead party dish since you can eat
them warmed up and they're just as
delicious served at room temperature
happy baking
i'm going to be thinking about that all
day long
[Music]
you